السجال بين اوكرانيا وروسيا بشان البحر
الاسود مستمر اوكرانيا دعت عبر وزير
خارجيتها الى تحويل البحر الاسود الى بحر
الناتو وضروره جعله منطقه منزوعه السلاح
رد الكريم بالرفض قائلا البحر الاسود لن
يكون ابدا بحرا للناتو وليس قابلا للتجزئه
البحر الاسود تتقاسم سواحله ست دول ويعتبر
مصدر سلطه لروسيا واساسا قويا لامنها
القومي اوكرانيا حافظت على وجودها بالبحر
الاسود عبر صد الهجمات الروسيه على ميناء
اوديسا استعادت اوكرانيا جزيره زميلي او
الثعبان من روسيا ما سمح لها بالبقاء في
البحر الاسود بعد سيطره روسيا على بعض
الموانئ واغلقت بعض الاخر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات